Thunder what was the first script that
you were ever commissioned to write the
the first script I was ever commissioned
to write not not an option you know I'd
written a couple of scripts on my own
that got optioned the first script I was
ever actually hired to write was for the
asylum it was a film called 200 miles
per hour which was basically a car
racing movie and the asylum they
distribute sort of what they call Mach
busters Mach busters and B movies
low-budget stuff right okay so was that
script easier to write than one that you
thought up on your own and were the
driving engine behind was it easier to
know that people were counting on you
and that there possibly could be money
behind it or is it harder to be your own
bandleader I think it's harder in a lot
of ways it's harder to write your own
script because there's nobody there's
nobody providing parameters guidelines
so you know you can do anything and that
means you have to control yourself you
have to narrow yourself down every day
you have to be your own sort of critic
and and that that requires thinking in a
lot of different ways whereas when you
know you have an approved storyline and
this is what they want and you just have
to deliver it in in some ways that
that's a lot easier because there are
there are fewer decisions to make
at every turn on the other hand that
that first script I had to write 200
miles per hour from the day they gave me
the assignment that needed to be done in
10 days so and I I'd never written a
feature script that quickly before so
that wasn't that was an interesting
challenge I was basically chained to my
computer 12 hours a day
you